anh
alo chào bạn
à quên mình quên chưa Xóa tâm sự đây à
Xin
chào bạn
hôm nay thì như mình có nói thì vẫn sẽ
làm một buổi thì mà chữa đồ nó các bạn
không ạ
những nhóm nào
muốn review
mặc chữa cốt
thì bình luận nhé
bạn cho oan thì mình
con gà mẹ mày tự tôi không biết tâm sự
cái gì ở
ạ
nhé chùm tiếp các nhóm đang hôm trước
đang chấm rổ nữa nhỉ
rồi phải không trước
gì thì đồng nghĩa việc là
tôi cứ coi mấy ông đang vẫn ổn nhá Thì
lúc đấy tôi
Ừ tôi không kiểm tra gì cả Nghe nhóm nào
mà không thấy ổn nhóm nào thấy mà cậu
đang mông lung thì cái tự thứ thì thì cứ
bình luận nha
hôm nay tôi sẽ chấm tiếp nhóm các nhóm
tiếp theo đúng ạ ờ
À hôm nay hôm nay thì ở nay tôi lại bận
mất rồi hôm nay chín rồi cho tôi hôm nay
tôi xin phép nghỉ sớm thì tôi còn à
Tôi đang định đi du lịch ngày mai thì
tối nay tôi định đi định đi Cậu
chuẩn bị các thứ luôn
anh nghe xã hôm nay sẽ nghỉ sớm đấy Mai
à Bạn nào tranh thủ cậu chữa trong lúc
livestream này được con không thì phải
sang thứ ba này rồi mới chữa được
nhé ạ
ở nhóm 14 này
xe 54 thì ạ
dùng mạng VNPT
Tôi đang dùng mạng FPT không rõ được
mạng khác thế nào nhớ không là mình như
VNPT từng được đánh giá là cũng ổn mà
ngay cái đây một tí ok
Em thích Viettel đây cái ca cái con nít
của bạn đấy khá hợp lý này
I am Mina Tôi thường thêm chữ amin gạch
ngang bia nữa mà những cái kiểu như thế
này thì tôi sẽ không dùng dấu phẩy mà
tôi sẽ là dùng dấu và à như thế nó sẽ
update đi thêu sắp xếp
anh đi theo access ngày nào hơi lạ
a cancel
không cần lại nhắc để chị bưu nữa chị ạ
cancel thôi không cần thêm trợ Jack đâu
thì nó sẽ là cậu nó kiểu ghi thì năng
đấy nó sẽ được để tới xem thử nhé
em rửa bạn ấy làm gì nhé Ừ tôi sẽ thử
nói theo cậu Cái con mít thì nó sẽ thế
nào nhé
cancel này Ok thì nó sẽ là cậu à
em giả sử cả 3 tính năng này thì mình sẽ
là
nó fix cho Ê mày updat bởi vì update thì
nó sẽ là cập nhật Cái cốt cũ gần như là
thế hoặc nó chỉnh sửa thêm một tí thôi
Chứ cái này sẽ Pixel nó sẽ là nó nó sẽ
ghi rồi đấy ạ
the best feature nghe này sau đó thì có
access
ở đâu check mà and access and cancel
sau đó thì amin Bio này thêm chữ s thì
hiểu nó là nhiều
ai chả thế
10 cái này từng tháng 1 thì có thể là
kiểu nhà thôi ok nghĩa là check Bill
đồng thời kiểu ngày ok Thế thôi
kiểm tra này lấy ID của Bill nào Okay
này
ừ ừ
em ở đâu
the first mentor nhà như hơi say
không thôi không nên làm nhà
Cho xem nhạc bé đi này
là phốt ngay thôi à
anh không cần lấy tôi ở đây cả là Bill
vẫn có thể gọi được kiểu nhà nhá
Vẫn kiểu gọi ngay được vì bản chất hàng
Alo quần nó đều nó vẫn hỗ trợ theo cầu
gọi cả đây tưởng ai được này
Ừ Ok ha mai đi nè bước đi này Baby sheep
này
Ừ nếu mà trong cùng thời gian này
Ê thằng đó
anh hai đi
Vì sao ghét nhỉ sẽ dùng ghét nhỉ
để ông kiểm tra xem là trong khung thời
gian đấy cũng các thứ tớ sắp tốt thời
gian đặt mà trong cái đó là hay đi khác
của cái đi bưu như này thì ông sẽ tạo
biến là biển trách
anh như này sao ông gọi đến Hà mít ở
kiểm tra tồn tại không thôi như này được
thế là xong
duyệt đơn này Các đơn cùng giờ sẽ bị hủy
ờ ờ không không không nên như ảnh không
không không nên duyệt được Kiểu như này
thì xem nhé người ta xử lý ở đây nó là à
à
thủ công hủy đơn để người dùng còn kiểm
tra lại xem có đơn kia như nào người một
cách nếu ông ấy muốn làm cái cậu là Hiển
thị đơn cũ ok ghét ở đây cũng được Ừ
dùng cao đấy cũng được cao kok
dùng này
thôi
làm gì có ai
nữ diễn viên này để làm gì nhỉ
đâu nhỉ
anh access bị sai chính tả rồi
v-internet điểm gì nhé
à à
đến hoài
Ừ ok
chị xem nha
vui tôi về đâu thằng như lần mấy cái
thằng even này không vừa ghi tên là một
cái gì cả em nhầm rồi Chuyên cái này vào
xong rồi nó sẽ có thể lấy
Ừ đấy lấy từ Y Vân người nói chuyện ra
ngay đúng rồi thay đổi trả về cái gì đâu
nhỉ À
cầu bình thường và ấn hành ngoái phải
tắt à
Ê mày không trả lời cái gì mày Nghỉ Đáng
Nhớ thế
à à mà trả về thằng đầu tiên à
3:00
ờ xử lý sự kiện even thì nó thường hay
làm chuyện đó không nên lấy cái dữ liệu
Trở về như này Anh thường cái này không
nên trả với một cái gì cả
3000 làm kiểu này đâu Ừ thì em muốn làm
hai cậu là bắt sự kiện các hứa thứ để nó
chạy thường ai chạy ngầm hơn
à Còn nếu mà em muốn để mà xử lý cái gì
Đói thì em lên đổi cái này thằng Action
làm cái hành động gì gì đó con kỹ Vân
thì nó sẽ hiểu là em Ok em kiểu đã duyệt
xong một cái gì như thế này đúng không
Thì nó sẽ nó sẽ tự động chạy ngầm gửi
mail hay là tự động tính lại cái đơn hay
Vân tự động tĩnh giá đơn Hoặc do tự động
gửi mail thông báo khách hàng hãy tự
động thông báo cho admin hay là tự động
cập nhật đơn hay nói chung vào nó chạy
ngầm và nó không nên trả về một cái gì
cả
anh không nên là các bạn làm thì vẫn làm
được rồi nhưng mà ý tôi ở không nên làm
cái gì cả thì nó mới tác dụng của Y Vân
và đấy do mà Y Vân nó sẽ gắn liền rất
nhiều giống như ở đây này Nó rất nhiều
về sự kiện khác gì mà làm Còn nếu mà em
làm theo cầu là Y Vân nó nó như một cái
á chân là là hành động mục xử lý mua gì
đó tôi chả với dữ liệu ngay khi nó là
ison hợp lý hơn ở tên là Tạo làm cái gì
hàm cái gì đó làm như thế nó hơi bị hơn
cả nên anh thì anh thấy
Ừ cái Y Vân này thì à
ừ ừ
Ừ ừ tạo cho này cũng được Nếu là sự về
sau access cái đó cập nhật một cái gì đó
Ai Cập nhật với cả chỗ khác như hai khá
ổn này nó xem lại đôi thích nhá
que đang đặt này
phải ai đi đâu ông lấy hết mà em ở xa
Build này toàn bộ tất cả bưu luôn
ở khách sạn làm như nào nhỉ
anh không ai làm từ này
sự kiện này đúng không
các em à Mình có thể que xào ghét xong
rồi vẫn à Vợ từng thằng để mát bếp được
mà
Anh nói như thế này
quay cái gì đấy chết nó sẽ như này à
đến chính xác tốt này bằng cái đoạn này
ba ngày sau đó thì gọi đến Hàm xếp thì
nó sẽ hiểu là khởi tạo khởi tạo
gọi đến cái even thôi mà lãnh sự kiện
các thứ thôi Nếu mà em có bắt sự kiện
của thằng bưu này là em à họp rô nó có
cái gì đó một cái sự kiện gì đó nhưng ở
đây anh thấy cũng chẳng lo xơ gì cả nó
nếu em muốn khởi tạo đối tượng để mà để
mà kiểu khi mà lưu lại thì nó sẽ kích
hoạt cá Y Vân một cái chích trung tâm
một người sự kiện với đó thì đây em cách
ở nhà cầu trường vật lại của em mình nó
thấy em thấy nó biết lập điện lại không
ạ
Có phải đây nó không khác gì Thằng này
nó chả khác gì cả
cứ sai sai rồi tôi thấy ông ấy đang làm
nó cứ bị sai sai cái gì khác nhỉ nó khác
gì đâu nhỉ
Ừ anh chỉ buồn cười à
thế này nếu mà ông muốn trả về kiểu dáng
mà mày sách ai đi thôi nó sẽ như này
thì mạnh ai đi thôi thì nó như này đó
à à
là để anh sẽ gọi riêng cho em nhé Thứ ba
nhé
A và ngay
em có xử lý ở đây theo như bà đang làm
đi lấy tất cả các sao tớ tăng Đạp xong
ngồi biến hàng đã Huy rồi lưu lại
ở lại như này nó trả về cái danh sách ai
đi đấy sẽ có một mạng sẽ ra đi truyền
vào không có tại tôi không biết lại
không đúng không rồi kìa Thôi trưa rồi
thử cái vụ là thằng này chả lấy dữ liệu
như thế này bây giờ cả nhà Thiện nhưng
Mở cách làm đây sẽ là như này đây tất cả
ra do ngồi chạy lần lượt từng tháng hủy
sôi lại được
Ok chứ
Ừ em nghỉ và đây là cancel này tai nạn à
Bỏ Đến Rồi khi nhìn nó thôi cũng được
cô đơn giản rồi thực ra như tôi thường
ngày làm thì để tránh việc lỗi người cái
này bạn đang trả về reason và bạn đấy ở
đây Chắc chắn này có chai cáp Cá thứ
nhưng mà bạn ah chắc chắn ở đây Bạn ấy
đang ra freefall về vi sinh có những thứ
nhưng mà chưa chai cá thì cả em mình tôi
vẫn thường ai luôn làm cái chai các ở
đây như này mà mình sẽ có một cái Return
đ
ở Tây Ban Nha Trần Ngạn đái
anh để trong trường hợp mà nếu gia sử
gia sự là có một cái lỗi gì đó xảy ra
thì mình sẽ ghi tên là Face đấy Sao kết
hợp việc là ông nên có virus gì gió Chắc
nhớ Đây Bên amin thì có thể tạm của quay
về biết được mấy giờ phải luôn chai cát
ở nhà chứ không hay ông bắt sự kiện của
gì để biết được mà nó cũng vấn đề không
ạ
Tôi muốn xem qua cái phải thôi
có gì thỉnh thoảng xem qua một wi-fi rút
kinh nghiệm cho mùa nhóm vậy thôi tôi
chưa hết thì cũng được rồi không ạ 57
U17 mất tích rồi à
à à
mọi người sẽ tạm xa nhau 17 vậy
cũng chẳng cập nhật thì cả bỏ qua nhóm
20 cũng hôm nay mới cập nhật các thứ thứ
Ok xem thử nha Could
See complete
complete without a rồi
viết tắt được không ai viết tắt rồi đấy
ừ ừ
almond cookies
Ê status request Trần quét lên
Ừ nếu là sự không có stock thì sao Nếu
không truyền sao tốt lên để dành nghỉ lạ
về ok with như này with ngay trông có vẻ
ốm
Bạn làm nhiêu Cậu là là gọi đến thằng
con thằng thằng cha đấy là con như này
nhiều bạn không trả cho biết vụ này đó
là có để thông qua thằng này gọi thằng
con này nữa xịn được
âm nhạc cá nhân tôi thì tôi
ghi kiểu này thì về sau mình sẽ khó sửa
cái gì đó tôi thích kiểu à Nhi heo cậu
dạng là biến anh biến hàng kiểu Đặng
cernex kiểu như này
a cho tôi vẫn muốn biến hàng ngày thành
văng chuyện như thế này
à à
Em
hãy sau đó thì quy xong rồi sà lách này
để cho
mình có thể hiểu vì sao mình muốn thêm
mình chỉ cần tắt đi Kết cục này lên như
này chẳng làm thế
so với sao Mình thích cái đã ký kết cục
này lên nó sẽ cậu sẽ lấy cực tiện hơn
à à
are you Human sex
khi sex
à à
em gà thì
mười kệ mấy cái phim này các bạn không
cần ít sếp nữa gửi bản chất chưa bồ của
ông chỉ có mỗi trường này thì ông ông có
thể đổ sư thẳng luôn được ô ngay luôn
được
chị sẽ không lỗi gì cả thì sẽ chả nói
mình mình chỉ truyền khi ơi bồ nhé tất
cả mình Chỉ truyền mà mỗi xa tốt rồi mà
không phải lo
ở đây CRD của anh
Hà mà
em chuyển lên
đã test mà đúng không ạ
ở chỗ nào nhỉ
nhóm này nhóm này còn chưa ông nhỉ Thấy
nhóm này có vẻ tuần chữa đấy Nhìn trong
bài toán vui vẻ phức tạp các đoạn kết
tham
Ôi trời hôm sau nhận định bình luận nhé
Để hôm sau tôi sẽ chữa cho nhà mày tôi
hiểu xem mà mình muốn làm gì đấy Ờ nhóm
Lord nút Delete bên admin nào ạ
à Dạ không làm không cần làm được thì
đang đi lên đâu
đang đi lấy đi
không không không đi led nên chỉ xóm mềm
thôi
ở Hà Nội à Không biết nó chỉ mày ông cái
vụ Nếu đôi khi xóa em xóa Hồi trước cái
thằng nhà thằng
ép wowww thì hình như chị Mai về rồi nó
có nguy cơ chết đó là thằng thằng
thằng con kế thừa thằng cha yêu cậu là
nó phone kỹ nhớ thêm cái ca Casa nữa Cái
phoneky này
Ừ ừ nó cắt sát Delete như này sẽ ra sao
đây là khi mà có thằng em cửa sổ dụng
còn này thì thì khi mà thằng cha bị xóa
lập tức hành con nó sẽ bay theo đó ngoại
nhưng mà bây giờ nếu ở mình làm theo
kiểu cơ chế Xóa mềm là bản chất là thằng
cha nó không hiểu bị xóa vẫn còn ở trong
database chẳng qua cái cột đĩa Tấn nó có
giá trị đúng không ạ nhưng mình vẫn muốn
hàng con nó cũng bay heo Nhưng cậu nó
cũng bị biến thành biết thực chất thì
nghe nó hợp lý đúng không ạ thì mấy ông
hiểu về toàn không ạ nghĩa là mình muốn
xóa hàng xóa mềm hàng tra thì làm con nó
cũng phải xóa mềm theo là sử thế tôi
không Tôi hiểu chưa đọc bài toán Nếu mà
restore là khôi phục nó lại thì thằng
con được khôi phục theo hay không nhưng
mà cái bài toán là thằng cha mất thì rõ
ràng thằng con nó sẽ bị lỗi hiển thị nếu
mà nó hiển thị ra không thấy đoàn cha nó
xin lỗi Đúng trước Thế bây giờ mình sẽ
làm thế nào Nếu mình muốn làm trong buộc
Anh ở Hội trước có một ông ông đấy có
Maria shop Elise
a subject là xóa nền ông ạ Nó có cái
Pocket là là
Casa này
Anh thật là mày nằm
nhiên là ông sẽ chạy thêm thư viện này
và cũng sẽ dùng cái á dùng cái riêng của
nó là cái
có thêm một cái chết nữa cho ông ông ghi
thêm là ông sẽ sẽ cát sa thêm với thằng
nào hãy kiểu như thế
tức sẽ sẽ xóa luôn cả thằng con của nó
ừ ừ
đây giống như ông đọc thì nó sẽ là Nếu
giả sử Xóa Thằng cha có vấn đề thì nó sẽ
thường robot nóng nó sẽ cho bác luôn cả
việc là xóa Thằng con cố vấn đề anh kiểu
thấy rất tiện nó sẽ trong hết 100 sân
kiểu như này
người ta thấy có vẻ ổn Đấy vốn hỗ trợ
được cho
a Quest này máy coudow trong Axelo Super
thuế khóa quần đùi ngoại đánh giá
ý chị là sao thỉnh thoảng mấy ông lên
mình nó sao ngoài việc ủng hộ thì nó còn
lưu lại những ngày ông đã đánh sao ấy về
sống xem lại nếu anh quên không ạ ạ
máy xúc tạm bỏ qua vụ xóa em nhé
từ trước kia Mạnh Hủy hai cái gì thì nói
Anh hiểu bị đơn dành cho thế giới nên xử
lý nhau thì cái đấy cho anh chạy được
còn không không nên xóa đi mấy
faster faster
faster có mùi gì không ổn ở đây thì
vectơ hơi nhiều xe máy là
à à
vẻ đẹp rồi vẫn avatar thấy bồ thôi chả
kệ tao xem với vectơ cái gì
à à
ở Barcelona
ở chung gái sự thật xem nha này
đấy nó không biết là có chạy không nên
tách làm 2 level nên để nói năm này à
à à
xem thêm
Ừ cái này update rồi phát tơ nếu mà ông
muốn sửa theo kiểu này xem nha
quan đến việc là cậu tối cấu trúc lại
cốt các thứ thứ
chứ không phải là chỉ đơn giản là cập
nhật thêm cốt thì nó sẽ update thôi
à à
[âm nhạc]
em xem cụ thể nào ạ
Ê cho hỏi về cơ bản từ thể cốt trong
cũng vợ là
không phải nói là dễ nhìn Không hẳn đâu
nha nói đó nhóm này cũng làm khá nhiều
a b Bảo sữa thì cũng chẳng biết sửa cái
gì Cá nhân tôi mà đập bình xe lại hết
cho biết hướng dẫn làm mới sửa rồi gì
nữa Saclo để cao sao ạ Chịu
thế này Tại sao làm như này
Ừ
tôi sẽ dùng zwickau
à à để lấy Tân Thành 1
ở mức cao vẫn được khi nào mới cao vẫn
được rồi cao đủ
chị sẽ Dạo này
ở Hàn Quốc classic hay nghe Thôi nghe
xong rồi
thì nó sẽ nhanh cậu tên của cột nó sẽ là
em không có thể tự đặt hưởng giống như
vừa rồi có mà flash
Cao đúng không
ba
ngày là được
ông chủ nhật
à à
Ý
Ngà huyết cao này có thể truyền thêm Cậu
tên cột mà
à à
I had crashed card xong nó vẽ xong
ở nếp choice
em sẽ hiểu rep cho để đẩy gì lắm
cho dùng hơi nhiều không thích lắm
Ừ ok à
chưa cập nhật
29 tháng 7
tuần trước
em xin thưa cháu ạ
nhưng mà chưa sửa đồ ngoài tôi tôi chữa
từ hôm 21 ngày chưa cập nhật thêm Ok
nhóm tiếp theo
à à
số 59 phút trước
Ok xem
à à
khi album api J5 ngày nào review
dàn nhạc
Anh Vinh ID PES
em bỏ qua mini Build chưa có
a location with bao nhiêu
à À đúng rồi tiện thể trả lời cho mấy
ông về cái vụ mà người nãy có bạn hỏi đó
là có bao nhiêu bản trong database thì
có bấy nhiêu mô đồ Ơ con này đúng hay
sai câu này là
à Không này chính xác chính xác theo
razzil thì nó là sai tại sao bởi vì à Ở
nó đối về lao ấy thì mua đồ nó thực thể
Nó là kiểu và những cái thằng ở trung
gian thì nó thay phốt thì nó không tính
là thực thể nghe hàng ra thì ạ nọ Thăng
Long Xăng thằng Viber Đấy Đó nó trung
gian thôi thì mình
thực tế là và thằng đồ về thằng nào ấy
thì những người trung gian đầy nó lại
còn chơi cơ chế à
à Không vẫn có cô tự động tăng 23 Vân
này ra là không càng không nên khẳng
định nó thuộc thể với được
k Không lẽ khẳng định nó mua đồ với mũ
đều sẽ có
là một đại đi mà rõ dùng tay vơ thì nó
sẽ cột hóa chính nón thường là liên quan
đến là hai cột của bảng khác đầu trước
đấy thì thì không phải cột ID tưởng cũng
tăng với cả đấy nghe đấy mà level thì
thằng các bạn sẽ còn biết khái niệm
roswell
hay phát
xe tải file word table ơi bà thay boad
mua đồ ạ Nó cũng có nó có nhắc đến nhưng
mà nó không như này
có thể gọi đến file đẳng luôn cho nó
không nó thưa vẫn có thể khai báo
Harvard mua đồ được nhé Có nó vẫn hỗ trợ
cho việc là
đây đại nó có khái niệm là nó sẽ không
extant hỏng mua đồ nữa mà nó là x theo
thằng file ghost rồi nó trung gian kiểu
như này đấy
Ừ cái kiểu như này cơ nhưng nó không xịn
được không nhưng mà bộ đồ thực sự mình
ở cấp thứ và nó sẽ kiểu mình sẽ wifi vvđ
có thử thứ kiểu như này cơ hơi dị một tí
tôi tôi không làm kiểu ngày bạn và tôi
khuyên mấy ông ở thực sự là không nên
làm ngay Tại sao tại sao đó là nó hỗ trợ
nhưng mà hãy nhớ đối thằng razzil thì
thì thằng thằng bộ đồ nào sẽ có cột tự
động tăng hay các hình thức và chỉ một
cuộc khỏi chích gì đó những thành ra là
kẹp iPad của mày và phải biết thêm những
cái Hàn nhưng còn Viber nữa Nó lằng
nhằng lắm đấy nên là ông cứ phải bảo là
có bao nhiêu ở bảng thì bấy nhiêu Mua đồ
và este thành Model đừng nói extend
hoàng ai biết làm gì cả những cái hàm
của thằng file boot này nó còn thiếu cơ
vẫn còn thiếu nhé nhưng thành ra là nó
vẫn chưa tối ưu cho file đâu nên là tôi
khuyên là ông nên có bao nhiêu vàng thì
bao nhiêu Mua đồ đừng kiểu cư phải Rập
khuôn theo lens bởi vì Lâm nó chỉ nó là
ý thức nào nó vẫn hỗ trợ mình cho dù
mình muốn thích làm thế nào nó vẫn hỗ
trợ vẫn tùy chỉnh được chứ nó không cố
định
Mà ông cái hình dung là
ạ bây giờ một là ông và một cái ngôi nhà
nó có đầy đủ nội thất rồi ông không được
phép chỉnh sửa cái gì cả cũng không phải
đập đi về sửa gì cả Sao ngôi nhà ông vẫn
thích kiểu như thì tùy chỉnh cái thử ông
thể sắp xếp vừa đầu là hai Hoàng Văn thì
thằng là đèo nó Facebook nó theo kiểu
mẫu hình rồi đấy Còn nếu mà giả sử nó ốp
y nguyên ông chỉ có thể dùng Nó bảo
không dùng chữa ông không được sửa thì
chỉ mấy thì nó lập platform rồi giống
kẹo web hay cái gì Giàu nó cũng gần như
cố định khó tùy chỉnh được hơn cái này
thì nên là tôi Mày đang dạy mấy ông leo
lắm chị mấy ông thuyết trình cho dì Hoa
thậm chí có cái á khái niệm mà hai cột
đọc khó chỉ hôm trước tôi được bà mẹ ông
ấy thì có khái niệm mà compa xechiep này
là nhiều cổ động tài chính thì có hạn
thư viện về cái này sẵn có Pocket để hỗ
trợ 2 cột là khóa chính đáng giờ hết ế
thực phẩm chứa nhiều cộng đồng hành
chính khoảng 12 nữa đấy cậu thấy nó xịn
Và thậm chí thậm chí là nếu mày không để
ý kĩ là ví dụ ví dụ nha
Ê hồi trước tao bị cái trò này dị cực ai
ví dụ ví dụ nhé
Ừ cái này là ông không kể không cần khai
báo thằng bên cạnh đúng không Bởi vì mặc
định cột
phoneky của ông là lâu kason ID Rồi cột
local cột trong bảng của ông ở cột ID
đúng chứ chứ biết à Thế bây giờ giả sử
là có hai cụ và quả trứng thì ra giống
như vừa rồi thì sao đấy thì ông sẽ phải
khai báo nó phải dạng mạc nhưng mà mới
đúng là sự giả sử lên là kiểu nó sẽ có
Avatar đi kiểu như này
Sơn nó sẽ nó sẽ phải nối đến tận hai cục
của ông kiểu dạng như thế này thì sao
vì nó không hiểu lý do ông ạ nghĩa là 2
cột quá chín đấy nối hai cột ở bản đồ cổ
của ông thì ông làm như thế nào thì rõ
ràng là nó em mặc định nó không hỗ trợ
điều này ấy thì ông sẽ phải có những cái
thư viện để mà hỗ trợ cái vụ này vào đâu
nhà rồi cũng đã từng làm bộ này rồi tự
từng tra rồi cờ thế
Anh đấy Anh nghĩa là mình mình làm thích
mình ở thích hợp và đương nhiên là vẫn
chạy được trong rất nhiều trường hợp nhé
Tôi phải dùng từ trang nhiều trường hợp
để có những kẻ hàm của lazaro ông không
biết được nó dịch cực giống như những
cái hàm Vừa rồi tôi nói vụ hai vuốt nó
có sẽ có cái á
cứ lên trang chủ của leo nó có cái hàm
là Attack và dtech của nó sẽ
à à
em về phần ship Dee
khi
họ tách à và detect rực
ở đây như thế này hồi trước của tôi dùng
cái tay vơ đây Tôi muốn cậu muốn gọn
nhanh đến cái thằng
Ê thằng kia xong rồi gọi cậu Lưu lại
thêm quyền lưu lại thêm ảnh vào cho nó
hiểu một người dùng mới điều hành hay gì
gì đó với Vân vẫn chưa một người dùng
một sinh viên có nhiều điểm ạ lại các
hơn thứ nó không làm được cái kiểu thế
nó làm cái này nó chỉ là mới giặt nội y
sắc có gì nhiều nhưng intro 2 cửa là 11
chứ không Insert được gọi là là hai cột
khóa chính không làm được điều đấy đấy
thì cái hầm Attack với đi tay Cường như
tôi không mở dạy mày ông một vì À cái
này thậm chí sai Eva này thì nó gần như
ở nó cốt để cho khiến cốt ngắn hơn thôi
chứ thực ra nó cũng bất tiện lắm và nó
khó hiểu nếu mà người mới vào đọc cái
này Đảm bảo chẳng hiểu cái gì cả đấy thì
tội không dậy mấy ông này này cái này
thì khiến cốt ngắn hơn thôi nhá nghĩa là
cốt Nhìn ông trong mẹ ở trong này ngầu
ấy ngắn nhưng thực ra thì bản chất nó xử
lý vẫn như nhau thôi nên là mình xử lý
kiểu ra gì tương tự Thế thì mấy cái này
thì như tôi đang bảo đấy nó nếu mà ông
muốn nối nhiều cột kiểu ông dùng cái thư
viện và những cái thư viện này đúng là
không hội chợ được tất cả những cái
thằng kiểu dùng xin lại bị tách hạt áo
kiểu này được bởi vì cái thằng này nói
chuyện 11 còn cái kia rồi Còn cái này nó
kiểu như nhiều không làm được đấy
anh đợi tôi vừa rồi tôi vừa nói quay
thêm cả việc là dùng chắc khít như thế
nào tiếp theo đó là thế có bao nhiêu bộ
mua đồ thì có bấy nhiêu controller đúng
hay sai thì ra mấy ông thấy ngay từ lúc
thực đang cốc thì nó đã sai rồi ông ạ Có
rất nhiều
bản chất nhá bản chất là controller có
bấy nhiêu mua đồ thì đúng là Có ngần đấy
controller để mà CRD tất cả xem thêm sửa
xóa một cái cơ bản Thế con những cái
tính năng khác ví dụ tính năng rất nhiều
tính năng của nâng cao mấy ông Định làm
Và thậm chí nó liên quan đến nhiều vàng
cùng một lúc thì rõ là ông cần nên tạo
một controller diêm ông ạ Và thậm chí là
như Gần đây tôi đang dạy mấy ông thì nó
là là ạ bây giờ tan sao lại có một cái
hàm để mà làm cái tính năng gì đó nhưng
mà vẫn là vẫn là ông có thể tách ra
thành nhiều tác chân xong rồi control
đấy Gọi những cái chân kia để thực hiện
một vài tính năng đơn này ví dụ Giả sử
giống như vừa nãy của bạn kia thì để mà
quỷ một cái đơn này Ngạn thì bạn gọi một
cái trần một cái event để mà kiểu hủy
đơn là sự thế
Vì thế nên là controller thì nó lại rất
là rất nhiều nên là tôi khuyên bà không
nên tống hết toàn bộ căn Trả lời vào
trong đầy đủ như này đương nhiên là toàn
bộ Cái này tăng hiệu nữa cpuz không sao
thường em tách nó vào trong admin này
kia kiểu này khá ổn này nhỏ nhỏ ra thì
nó còn hơn con như này về sau nó bị dài
nhiều quá
dù thời tiết ở
Anh đang chở cái gì nhỉ Thế đang nói gì
anh chữa nhóm này ở nhóm này à em à
mai cập nhật hôm 25
ở nhà hàng ngày hôm trước
anh ở đây
không biết hàng này của ông ấy gọi ở đâu
cơ
xe buýt một Loan hơi nhiều
đi xe máy quét ok ok nè
lessness Pearl connect
I wonder bay bikini cũng được
anh nghe lên để in like cảm này
em gà lái xe ổn hơn
ô ồ ghét này
đi ngủ đây rõ là lưu siren thế nào cái
việc location này Ông phải tốt hơn chỗ
khác ông xử lý này là nó trả về robeson
AD đây không ngờ vẫn lên tổng chỗ khác
để xử lý thật
a Galaxy A hay cao cùng lúc như thế này
đến cái hàm gì đó của thằng mua đồ thôi
nói chuyện 3
đây đây là sếp bạn ạ
anh được
khi xếp vào đây có phải vfat lại lá đi
ông nghỉ không nhớ lắm cái vụ này đó
We are they Knew You you ok rồi Nhớ cho
mặc thì có rồi
Ừ cái này ông ấy không vui tơn
Mở hộp eater tập cuối
được
để tui kê trái cát rồi
thế này ăn mì chỉ có mấy câu không thì
thôi
ừ ừ
25 26 cân d b
ô kê
rồi mà đúng
nhà gọi minh nha
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
à à
anh
alo em nghe theo
à à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ăn sáng chưa
Chưa bao giờ anh thấy rồi em cần chữa
phân công em làm về điểm danh sinh viên
tưởng chữa cho các nhóm khác ở nghỉ
bảo phân công với em đâu ạ
ở đâu đâu để xe mà tiền thì mình có
từ khóa này
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
đề ngành đúng không Bây giờ này
nào anh không hiểu lắm là em sẽ làm điểm
danh cho cả giọng của giáo viên nữa
Ừ nhưng mà Lương Văn gì không nhỉ thì
khi đăng ký tài khoản cho giáo viên thì
phải cần biết là giáo viên này là của
tao biết nào
Ừ
thì mình sẽ có ozid nằm trong luôn Bản
thích chờ được mà
Xóa đi chơi you ready
tiếp theo
à à
Ở đây có điểm danh là đúng không điểm
danh sẽ là điểm danh có Note là cả đúng
rồi ca
ca này chơi đi này xúc xích cái đi có xe
đi Dead này
ở trên đền ok ok rồi này à
thì mình sẽ có bảng phân công ở bây giờ
để anh thì đặt câu hỏi nha một lớp của
em
học được bao nhiêu môn một nước nhiều
mụn
I am bình tĩnh em xóa cả năm học ở trong
lớp đi bởi vì Ánh thành của em có năm
học rồi
đúng không
ừ ừ
một lớp học được môn
01 môn cũng
A1 môn cũng thể được học ở nhiều lớp
đúng chứ đúng rồi ạ
thêm một lớp 1 môn được dạy bởi bao
nhiêu giáo viên một lớp 1 mũi ở cùng bộ
lốp của một môn được dạy bởi bao nhiêu
giáo viên tại một thời điểm dạy bởi một
giáo viên giáo viên không ạ thì thì bạn
sẽ thì nó sẽ là
như anh vừa nói thì nó sẽ là mã lớp mã
môn sẽ khóa chính còn là mã Giáo viên sẽ
không phải là khóa chính nghĩa một bảng
này nó sẽ có 3 cột mình sẽ có mã bạn lớp
mã giáo viên
hai nước Mã giáo viên
Ừ mạng lớp mã môn mã môn học Tài chính
về bản chất thì nó vẫn là khóa ngoại rồi
đúng không nó sẽ là khóa chính nữa còn
nhưng mà mã giáo viên không phải khóa
chính
lại cứ ghi mã thuật viên rồi đấy
bây giờ đấy Tại sao nó lại khái niệm
không phải nói chính thì bởi vì Nếu giả
sử cả 3 cục cho cùng họ là quá trình
đúng không nhiều thức là một lớp 1 môn
có thể dạy bởi nhiều giáo viên về sao ví
dụ nha ví dụ ở đây cái ruộng ra sự lớp à
lớp 01 này dạy môn à 1 pp này đúng không
Mà có có giáo viên Long dậy chẳng hạn
đúng không Nếu mà giả sử là sửa là có
giáo viên Tuấn thì rõ ràng là phải xóa
giáo viên Long đi Tuấn mới được phép
nhận nếu mà giả sử hai cột làm ạ lớp mã
môn là khóa chính thôi còn nếu mà
ở ba cột của Ngọc Hà chính thì nóng dậy
được vẫn cũng dậy được
à tại em vẫn đang xem YouTube nhỏ đúng
không để anh ra thử cho em đang sợ anh
anh cho xem Google sheet sẽ dễ hiểu này
mình sẽ có lớp này Ngô này giáo viên này
Nếu giả sử là lúc đầu cho sự 3 cột cùng
là phải xử lý ngay đi
á nhon thì à lớp 01 này muốn TP này nó
viên Long dậy được này cũng là lớp không
mộ đấy cũng muốn p tập viên Tuấn cũng
lại được nó sẽ không vào lỗi gì cả Bởi
vì rõ ràng mà cô giáo viên nó không gặp
lại chỉ cả ba cái Không lặp lại nó báo
lỗi trong trường hợp như thế này nó mới
vào lỗi thôi đấy như này là người báo
lỗi này
ờ ờ
là khóa chính thôi thì rõ ràng là khi mà
nhập bạn khi nhập bạn Tuấn vào thì bạn
Long bắt buộc nó sẽ bị báo lỗi luôn bởi
vì hai cột này Nói chung có tuổi hay còn
Nói chung nó sẽ vào lỗ luôn đấy còn Nếu
giả sử là chỉ có một cột là khóa chính
anh em có 1 lớp 11 môn là phải chính thì
rõ ràng là ngay từ lúc lặp lại cái lớp
một này nó bảo lỗ rồi như thế không được
vậy Rõ ràng Nếu mà giả sử là môn esquare
Tuấn dậy cũng được đúng không Thế là nó
vô nó lỗi của bia không gặp lại cái một
mới rồi đúng chứ
đã nhiều lần nào em hiểu rồi ạ ạ
Ừ thì đấy nghĩa trong bảng phân công này
sẽ có lớp môn nó phải đúng thôi
Lý Hải
Ừ OK OK anh lại còn còn sao nói gì không
anh em nghĩ là không ạ ok
anh làm tí thôi bác ạ
ừ ừ
nhé
Ừ Ok Được được em gọi mi tin nha
[âm nhạc]
cũng phải đi đấy à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
Xin chào em
30 31
à à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
định được
à à
thì alo anh anh nghe tiếng rồi Ok ok
[âm nhạc]
buổi chiếu điểm danh
ừ ừ
thì yêu chưa bỏ thì cái phần này
em làm Triều Tiên là điểm danh thì em sẽ
lại là cá heo đến thời gian điểm danh
bên
ăn mặc cách scan scan ở bên
was also a
Ừ cái gọi có số là trì nó sẽ muốn là tự
động là đến từ thời điểm em xem cái thì
nó làm gì Xa Lạ
Anh chỉ yêu em Em bị Dự kiến là trong
cái ship tiền shipper này em chia làm 3
ship 3k thì nó sẽ có cá bắt đầu kết thúc
thì em lấy ra là để từ lúc ban đầu nữa
sẽ chuyển sang trạng thái là có
thái là bắt đầu ca hết ca và hình ảnh
thì em muốn cài nó cứ đến nó lắm Nó lấy
dữ liệu để chuyển động lại chỉ là lấy Độ
ca chứ là lúc
ở độ cao của nó là một lúc như này Đây
là 7 giờ đến 12 giờ thì xong là hay là
hết ra rồi
bây giờ đến 12 giờ thì còn ở trong ca
chúng ta từ 162 nhưng mà khen tình bình
tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh cái
gì có sao tốt của em là gì cơ
1231 thì nó là mặc định là chưa đến giờ
Hay là đang trong ca và 3 là hết ra biệt
danh ông không ai làm thấy thả
anh buồn cười đi
Âm Nhạc
Khi dòng status nó không phải nằm kiểu
đấy à
điểm danh chứ Cốt em lấy thời gian thực
tế để biết được mà đúng không
phải đấy vẫn là kiểm tra kiểm tra liên
tục không không đi gọi xong đêm rồi cũng
cho rồi đấy ạ
cho nên muốn kiểm tra liên tục là là nó
đang có đang được khuyết điểm danh không
thôi kệ thôi
Ừ có lẽ là này ngay từ đoạn này em làm à
Sai rồi bảo em thử ca nó không có tâm
đến việc là ca ca ca sáng ca tối có gì
đó nói chị mỗi cái hiện tại nói thôi là
nó chỉ con nút để điểm danh cái hiện đại
thôi Em chỉ là bắt đầu em định lấy nhưng
mà xóa thì sao mà bị để xem cả ngày nay
những ngôi sao xem việc này luôn Ờ cái
lịch sử thì cái lịch sử khác chị xem cái
gì sửa sang này thì bây giờ phải sang
bên này xem
có mặc áo
Nếu thế thì đáng lẽ là em em sẽ phải
quay quay lại lên kênh Nếu thế thì em
phải xem đừng có thợ đến với cái rồi
Hiện tại nó cả thứ bao nhiêu Rồi những
cái ca trên nó sẽ mặc định luôn ẩn và
luôn không có nút để bẩn thỉu không Nói
chung là đến cạ đến ca nào nó mới hiển
thị ra ca ca đấy thôi Ví dụ ở bây giờ
buổi sáng thì chị Mỗi sáng rồi buổi
chiều buổi tối không nhìn chị ta đợi hết
và nếu mà đến buổi chiều rồi thì chị
buổi sáng buổi chiều thôi và sáng sẽ
không được Bấm vào thế ngồi và tiếp tục
thế nếu mà đến tối rồi thì chỉ được cái
điểm danh buổi tối thôi còn cà sa cá
chiều không được phép bấm
không không chú làm thế là chú cập nhật
DB theo thời gian linh linh động sửa sai
chú cập nhật rất nhiều Bây giờ có ở Chú
đang có 1.000 nhân viên anh đúng không
nhỉ nhân viên một nhân viên điểm nay bao
lần một nhân viên điểm danh 6 lần Ờ một
tháng tổng cộng bao nhiêu Nhưng mà vấn
đề cái này nó tắt nhiều điểm danh
anh em cho sẽ trách nhiệm điểm danh nó
chỉ là bảng liên quan đến thời gian bị
danh
em cũng không cần phải làm thế Cả kiểm
tra kiểm tra lại được mà kiểm tra
anh không Không cần phải lưu lại sản
xuất từ đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ
Anh hiểu ý em là để mà để check mà bản
chất là nó vẫn là ít theo check ngọng
rất nhanh không cần phải lưu lại việc
đây
khi mở đây là bắt đầu còn con để mua đến
danh nào
nghe tiếng Anh làm được điểm Anh các thứ
ấy rồi đúng không ạ
à à
bạn này điểm danh rồi nữa à
là qua rồi thì nó sẽ không được tiền anh
ngồi lúc nào sẽ là lưu ấy ạ
Ừ ok Anh cho em
này về xong nhiều mà à
Anh
tạo để chuẩn bị cho việc làm sao Huy
Lượng thì nó cần trắm tháng để xem Đúng
rồi chạy ship
nhầm nhân viên khác siba
anh quyền anh thế giới hạn
ở thị xã Bình là một chỉ một cho thời
gian anh em một lần thì em không nhưng
mà đám ấy đáng lẽ cái thích cao anh phải
để nó được phép để nun thay vì nó không
Vì Em cảm nhận như em kẹt là hai xem
thêm làm vậy thì lại em dùng cái scandal
thế thì cứ là tầm 12 giờ đêm thì nó sẽ
tự khen tất cả nhân viên nào
khi
Nhìn nôn ở Lan luôn thôi
ờ ờ
ở Hà luôn nó nhẹ hơn mình phải cập nhật
in xơ và thế
chưa Vì nếu mà nhân viên
nhưng theo hiểu thì là nhấm em không
được danh thì hôm đấy nó sẽ không chết
bà đi À đúng rồi Đúng rồi
em như thế nào thì cần cái này nó lại
như này còn bên danh gọi hiện tại nhà
nhưng không có gì Sáng này trắng tinh
như thế này
đúng rồi thì chuyện sau đó thì em sẽ em
em chỉ cần kiểm tra thôi
ô tô Canada ạ
cái cái này nó là bài toán mà là chủ
sinh ra thì bị Jack arabe lúc này thì để
phun kem điều này cũng phải làm cái kiểu
là cái dữ liệu này chú lấy về đúng không
Rồi chú sẽ
thủ sẽ này
em dậy tự zarist là khi mà hiển thị ra
cái tháng này
này
Blade những cái ngày mà nó thiếu điểm
danh
I see mà xem cái lên đồ này chứ không
phải chú ý sốt Hải Phòng được bày
Anh hiểu rồi Anh không
những hôm nào chứa điểm danh thì chú chỉ
được sinh ra nhiều bài toán nó sẽ phức
tạp hơn một tí Nếu mà nhưng mà mình mình
không lưu ở trong pp nó nặng quá người
bản chất là không điểm 0 điểm cho anh
thì không lưu quan điểm đơn giản thế
thôi Tại sao mình lại lưu lại những cái
mình không điểm danh đúng không
anh đúng không em Em đang bị làm là đang
bị lạm dụng database quá thế sai mà bản
chất đây mình sẽ chỉ lưu những cái cái
lưu thôi
đúng không
ở đây mình chỉ lưu hiện tại cần lưu thôi
ở những những cái nào mà không có thì
mình mình không cần phải lưu nhưng mà
máy tính mình sẽ tự động tính tính ra hả
lương nữa Tỉnh đưa về sau em khá lâu rồi
em không nhớ ở tại sao lại theo kiểu đấy
Ơ con này mua về chạy thằng này thì em
để môi tháng này
cái này thì em cái này thì sẽ đổi bên
này thì nó sẽ sang cả bên chọn trọng hay
gì tháo bạn 5A
ừ ừ
Ừ OK OK anh sống ảo kem chồng vậy Anh
xin lỗi em à Ờ
tao bay kiểu đấy anh không duyệt cậu Lưu
lại nhiều quá à
rồi sửa sau gửi xong hết toàn bộ địa gửi
tỉnh tối ưu hay là làm gì tính sau và
làm dứt điểm xong việc đi đã nếu mà còn
thời gian thì mình bắt đầu tính bởi vì
mình còn Tết Tùng nó thử nữa
nếu mà rút kinh nghiệm là thế đó là đây
mình không nên lưu Quá nhiều thứ và
đương nhiên à nó sẽ có phải toán đánh
đổi đó là nếu mà ta bây không lưu thì cứ
mỗi mình lại lúc mỗi lần mình lấy ra
mình sẽ phải tính toán lại mà nó sẽ bị
Hơi bị tốn hơi bị tốn thời gian để tính
toán bất công xử lý đúng không Anh ấn
nhầm thì lần trước có một lần là dùng
cái prince charmant lần luôn cho nó khô
da bạn nhé Thì em thấy ô Channel là được
anh ạ
Ừ thế thì
đó mà cậu Nếu mà giả sử mà em nếu mà do
sửa lại mà
vì
mỗi lần em vào đây xem Nó lại mất công
trình tòa lại chẳng hạn đúng không Thì
cái đấy Mình có thể lưu lại cách cái thứ
thấy thì tính sau Nhưng nói chung gần
như là mình hạn chế lưu lại trong đây có
nhiều vì cái bảng này nó sẽ rất là nặng
đúng chứ nặng bởi vì sẽ nặng kinh khủng
có 1.000 nhân viên điểm danh đâu một
ngày tận 6 lần xong rồi
làm từ 15 mình ra là nhiều nó nhiều đúng
không
Đây thì tất cả nhân viên kế toán và bên
nhà quản lý đều có cái chức năng Xem lại
lịch sử rang xót và thì ta nhìn nhau cả
tươi canxi này thì làm về xem trạng thái
của cái phòng ban mình à
để người sau có hệ thống kê ra thằng đấy
Thực ra là nó không có tâm mấy cái dầu
giấc mười mấy nó chỉ cần thống kê ra là
trong tháng này thằng đấy đi muộn bao
lần các thử thử thử thôi
bí ngô làm gì đấy
Đúng không Nó nhìn cái này nó bị đau mắt
thì cái nhìn nghe bị đau mắt nó không
còn quan tâm cụ thể giờ đâu có một sự
thật như thế này nha Đó là em có thể
ngay từ cái đoạn này đánh em phải tự
chỉnh nhé em thì các em không cần quan
tâm giờ nếu mà giàu nó đúng thì on time
thì có thể bỏ qua không cần hiển thị giờ
thấy cờ thế nó chỉ quan tâm chỉ quan tâm
mình những cái Giờ nó cứ phạm thôi
em hãy hiểu vấn đề không Thế này là cái
đoạn này Thực ra là nếu nó làm chuẩn hơn
thì mình sẽ phải cân nhắc sắp xếp lại có
thể thử Thực ra là số giờ nó bị đẩy lên
mà là
Ừ nó thằng cái đơn này chưa có chỉnh Nếu
mà cùng không Giờ làm sao nó đẩy lên
được nghỉ vẫn đầy lên à Cũng Giờ sao anh
ví dụ nó cùng tám được cùng 16 giờ thì
nó phải cùng ở dưới đúng không
Không phải thật ra bởi vì đây em tùy
chỉnh
ở
gốc của nó là cái này không có wifi
không có
em loi mình thêm được mà mình thấy lấy
cạnh luôn có cho gọi là dùng hoa kia là
tiếp theo đấy ạ
ở chỗ này thì anh hả gì anh à cái đấy em
thêm nó là Bảo mà em thêm bên cạnh như
sau được mà
ổn rồi còn lại này hiểu được bài toán
rồi Cái này nó không phải tự do thì cái
gì thì là chị iWin học là lấy được không
Nghĩa là on hand Đúng rồi thì em không
cần thì bị ra nhưng những cái người quản
lý ra nó không có tâm đến việc nhân viên
phải đi làm rồi nào giờ nào đúng như nó
thì quan tâm mà đi muộn vào những giờ
nào nghiêm trọng như thế nào thôi
ai dọn
phạm lỗi thôi rồi
bán hơn em nhìn nó đau mắt không Em có
mua em một phòng của em tận mười mấy
thằng em cứ ngồi ngồi sau nha
sau đó hả
Đúng rồi nhìn cái này nhưng cái này nó
sẽ bị đau mắt đúng không Thì bây giờ em
thay nó bằng
chỉ thị dầu của đấy đại khá giờ của
những thằng có vấn đề thôi thì nó sẽ hóa
hơn
em nghĩ em nghĩ em nghĩ là kiểu là có
thể công ty bảo đi tiểu Đúng rồi không
nghĩ là sẽ làm đi tìm hiểu sao nó lại
xem thời gian đến học như thế nào
mà vì nó có thể cho ra thì nó
không quan trọng thì việc nó nó đi giờ
đúng thì kệ nó chứ
anh em không rảnh thế em quan tâm cái
này cả ngày đâu thật à
anh em em ngồi em ngồi soi nhân viên em
đi đúng giờ ở chẳng để làm gì cả đúng
không
em em hiển thị ra cái sai rồi cô để làm
gì nhân viên có ý kiến thì mở cái này ra
bảo là tại sao hôm qua mới đến muộn 10
phút như này thế thôi Có cái mà chửi
nhân viên thôi chứ chả mơ khen nhân viên
khi mà như liên tục đi đúng giờ hay đi
sớm sự như thế chẳng quan tâm hãy nên
lên à Ờ tính sao em ạ
Tháng này nó đã hỏi là một phần đường
ranh này thì cái như bọn sữa là xác em
rồi sẽ quản lý để lên có đồng ý làm bạn
luôn
nhé cũng được anh sẽ làm điều gì cho
nhận chai này hay là xác nhận cả nhóm
này
có hiện tượng nằm ở chứ thấy chưa từng
Hà Nội
ghế sau rồi Còn nút xác nhận ở dưới cùng
phẩm cải ra xác nhận
có nhiều ạ
Ừ ừ thì nó vẫn ở dược từng hàng má kế
toán nó vẫn chưa từng hàng mà đây là bên
quản lý của Lý thủ công an đấy quản lý
cũng chỉ từng thẳng
nên anh mới bảo là để quản lý đỡ đau mắt
thì nên hiển thị cái giờ cái cái dầu vi
phạm thôi chứ bây giờ nó đã giữ mất công
việc từng hàng rồi em ông Ông Hiển thị
đầy đủ tất cả múi giờ ra cho nó nhìn nó
bị đau mạnh nữa Cái này cũng thấy nhỉ
đúng rồi cần chi tiết là gì nữa
Ừ Thế làm chung một api mà đúng không ạ
anh nói chung à cả cả anh đã bảo duyệt
cá nhân mà có cái nút ở dưới ở nút kiểu
copper đấy là cái nút confirm rửa đấy để
mà kiểu xác thực đây thì cũng làm cá
nhân này Ừ thì thì chỉ hiển thị không
Giờ vi phạm thôi
ẩn rồi đi cái đấy thức ra đơn giản mà
nếu mà nếu mà on than thì không có ừ thì
đấy nghĩa là cho trú ẩn rồi Đi kiểu thế
Nếu chú vẫn muốn thì đi màu làm cho thơm
ra bài toán người dùng ấy người dùng sẽ
luôn để ý màu đầu tiên người dùng ít đọc
chữ người dùng sẽ quan tâm bầu đầu tiên
đấy Xong rồi em ở ngay trên ngay có cái
trên này em sẽ khi em bấm vào cá nhân
của một người em em tô màu ở ngay trên
Ấn thử cá nhân một người đi
ấy xong rồi em sẽ có cái ngay trên cái
chỗ ngay cạnh nó có phơ mấy Nó sẽ hiển
thị ra Ví dụ là á Không không không Ở ở
ngay bên này này này ngay bên trái này
thì mới trả đây em sẽ để em sẽ ghi 2.1
ưng cái bên cạnh cho anh là kiểu Ờ đúng
rồi hai trần gian thời gian không đi hay
chậm Bên cạnh đó là số số của cái thằng
này
số lần của Hoài vi phạm cái gì đó như
thế người dùng chỉ cần thế rồi
hiểu về toàn không có đấy thì nó sẽ giờ
đơn giản người dùng đúng không người
dùng sẽ chả cần phải đến đúng không
người dùng cũng sẽ hiểu ốm lắm là người
dùng kiểu nhớ mang máng ở tháng này như
là tuần này đến muộn ba phát Đấy xong
rồi dùng vào đây kiểm tra đúng trong
phần mềm xác thực đến muộn khi người
dùng nhấn con Thơm xong đúng không
đấy à khiển nó nhẹ bên quản lý rồi đúng
không
Bí Ẩn
Ừ Ok chắc chỉ thấy em nghỉ còn còn còn
đi nữa không được kế toán và bên siêu
nhỉ
Ừ Ừ cái đấy tuần sau hỏi đi ông cứ làm
xong mấy ngày chưa kìa Cái đấy thì làng
Nghĩa xóm ạ Có siêu à Thế em trước thì
đang nói là nó về phần
cái time là gì mà mình là em thêm chị
MTB chạy vì nó sẽ sáng ở
Ừ ừ thì nghỉ thôi cả anh không cho em có
bảo ý những phải đẩy những cái phát lên
trên mình cái tham đấy những cái cấu
hình sẽ luôn sẽ gộp chung vào một cái
Menu là menu Compaq kiểu cấu hình sẽ
tinh ấy thôi để xuống dưới cùng cái cái
đấy thôi
I thought I
Ừ có gì nữa không
Ok Ok
Xin lỗi
anh em ok nhé
đi có việc rồi nói cho buổi hôm nay chữa
thì chả chữa tương đối các bạn có những
nhóm bảo nó cần muốn góp ý các thử thì
Ừ thứ ba tuần sau hoặc là thứ 5 nhé thứ
ba để chắc à hơi khó vì thử ma Tôi muốn
hồi cốt kiểu các thứ tiết Nếu mà tôi nếu
mà nhóm nào cần nhờ thì thứ ba thôi vẫn
sẽ chữa Còn không thì sẽ là thứ năm thứ
bảy không ạ Ok nhỉ
em nói chào các bạn nhé